remember uh in case you've forgotten
because i rarely mention it
we are a program mostly funded and
supported
by members who sign up at
joinpackman.com consider yourself
invited go to joinpacman.com grab a
membership
both joe biden and kamala harris had
very
solid appearances in interviews and
press conferences over the weekend i'm
going to talk about it many of you have
been saying david you know as important
as as it is to expose
the insanity of trump now that we have a
ticket
including not just the presidential
nominee but also a vice presidential
nominee
let's highlight what they are doing and
the contrast of sanity that they bring
to the table
and that's exactly what we're going to
do let's start
with vp nominee kamala harris kamala
harris was interviewed
by cnn's dana bash this is one of the
first major interviews that kamala
harris did
and i i know that the bar is so low
because of donald trump and mike pence
but kamala harris
was coherent she met that low bar she
answered the questions she was asked
that's a higher bar for elected
officials who often don't even answer
the questions that they are asked
and she precisely and accurately
expanded on each question
to expose the pathetic failings of the
trump administration
she's not as far left as i am kamala
harris
but it would be a serious breath of
fresh air
just to have people who can speak and
interact coherently
in a position of power after the last
four years but kamala harris does more
than that she actually put on a clinic
in terms of how to be interviewed and
how to answer questions
not dodging but answering
and then doing more so we're going to
look at a few clips of this and the
context i would be thinking about
as you watch the one i was thinking
about is
how is mike pence going to handle kamal
harris during the upcoming debate
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
later on when that debate will be
happening and sort of the details of it
first clip dana bash asks whether
the economic recovery albeit slow is a
threat to biden harris
because as the economy improves it could
pull people back over to donald trump
and kamala harris very quickly gets to
the heart of the issue
which is this is a pandemic you can't
just go around
sacrificing whatever or whoever you need
to
in order to temporarily improve jobs
numbers take a look at our answer
on the economy yeah new jobs numbers out
at the end of the week
uh show that unemployment is at 8.4
percent
and not great but about where president
obama had it in 2012.
and so my question is are you worried
despite the fact that it's again not
great
that things are coming back to the point
where where donald trump could have
uh more meat on the bone for his
economic argument that it's coming back
listen i want the american people
to to be able to work i want that we
have
jobs that are filled by the hard-working
people who want to work
and want to have the dignity that comes
with good work
but there is no question that donald
trump has
been an abject failure and incompetent
when it comes to addressing the severe
job loss that has happened as a result
of the pandemic
because he has failed to address the
pandemic itself
and when we look at this path hopefully
at some point to recovery
his perspective cannot be our
perspective because
his perspective for too long is to talk
about how well the economy is doing
based on how rich people are doing
we need to talk about how the economy is
doing based on how working people are
doing
and right now working people are
suffering people are standing
or sitting in their cars in food lines
for hours
what i like about this is that kamala
harris won't allow the conversation
to simply be about the unemployment rate
is now
coming down or stocks are up or we are
getting jobs back that we lost she
points out
that's garbage it ignores why we are
here and that's the big picture that
kamala harris
i hope is going to be able to utilize
and expose during the debate with mike
pence so if she does
this with the pence debate anytime that
mike pence points out
you know august saw some of the best new
jobs numbers
she needs to point out not only is a
partial recovery of what we lost
not that good all of it is much worse
because of the
failed handling of coronavirus then the
topic that comes up is foreign
interference
and i like what kamala harris does here
in that she is asked about russia do you
believe russia's meddling
and we know that there are some people
who reject that idea despite the fact
that
mueller confirmed it the senate select
report confirmed okay it's
etc there are some people who have sort
of like a visceral reaction anytime
sometimes mentions russia they think
it's a conspiracy theory
and i like what kamala harris does which
she acknowledges that
of course russia's doing this but she
immediately points to the domestic voter
suppression that the trump
administration is engaged in
and won't allow the story or the
question to only be
do you believe russia or not she knows
that
just dealing with that could be a turn
off to some viewers
and she says trump is suppressing the
vote take a look at this
russia yeah the department of homeland
security
bulletin said that russia is trying to
amplify
amplify claims that mail-in voting will
lead to widespread
voting fraud and undermine the public's
trust in the upcoming election
are you worried that russian
interference could cost you the election
i am clear that russia interfered in the
election of president of the united
states in 2016.
i serve on the senate intelligence
committee we have published
detailed reports about exactly what we
believe happened
and and i do believe that there will be
foreign interference in the 2020
election
and that russia will be at the front of
the line could it cost you the white
house
theoretically of course yes
and that's based on um what you're
hearing publicly or you mentioned you're
on the same
list let me just tell you something i we
have to be a realist and i'm a realist
about it joe's a realist about it
we have classic voter suppression at
play in this election coming up
where after the supreme court gutted
the voting rights act with shelby v
holder in 2013
dozens of states passed laws that were
designed to suppress the black vote
to suppress students from voting to
suppress our indigenous people from
support
from voting so much so that in north
carolina court appeals said it was
the the law was passed with surgical
precision
to to get in the way of black voters
from voting this is a good focus point
that this is a smart thing to focus on
because
the idea of the current administration
suppressing the vote
is going to be much more universally
compelling than
an adjudication of to what degree do you
believe russia is doing this or doing
that and what
again what i really like about this
interview is kamala harris answers every
question she doesn't dodge the question
but then she expands with proper context
it's classic interview and media
training answer the question
and then expand the framing barack obama
was excellent at doing this on the first
question about the economy
notice she was asked what about these
improving job numbers
and she said well improving relative to
the worst numbers we've ever had
and overall much worse because of
trump's failed response
that's how you answer a question here do
you believe russian meddling yeah
i believe russia will meddle and this is
way bigger
because we've got domestic voter
suppression purging of votes
voters in disproportionately black areas
and on and on this is how you actually
deal with issues in interviews now one
more
clip and i encourage you to check out
the full interview kamala harris on
whether she would trust a coronavirus
vaccine
endorsed by donald trump this is crucial
we know that trump's cdc sent out a
letter saying be ready for a vaccine at
the end of october or early november
she has to be careful here kamala harris
does because anytime you say you won't
trust a vaccine
you're starting to dabble in maybe being
associated with anti-vaxxerism and
that's not what this is about this is
not about do we trust vaccines in
general
do back vaccines work in general it's is
trump for political reasons
going to try to force something that's
just not yet ready kamala harris does
a perfect job of refocusing the question
promised a coronavirus vaccine by the
end of the year or maybe
sooner would you trust that vaccine i
think that we have learned
since this pandemic started but really
before that that there's very little
that we can trust that comes out of
donald trump's mouth
from the beginning of this pandemic he
has called it a hoax
he has muzzled the public health experts
he has minimized the seriousness of it
he has created false expectations
for the american people and american
families even though if he had listened
to the scientists and the experts
he would have understood the gravity of
it and
the power that he is president of the
united states has to actually save lives
and none of those were his priorities
his priority was to
to do whatever he thought was
politically expedient
and um so no i would not trust his word
i would trust the word of public health
experts and scientists but not donald
trump
this is really a clinic on how to answer
it's not
i do or don't trust the vaccine
it's i don't make a decision on whether
the vaccine is okay
on trump's word because trump is
unreliable
it's not about vaccines being the
problem
and getting into maybe oh is she maybe
against vaccines
no it's about i don't trust trump's word
on anything
and as a media literacy person as a fan
of the techniques of
interviewing and being interviewed this
is really well done
by kamal harris i am very much looking
forward to the vp debate which we'll
talk about a little bit later
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches and they're giving you up to 30
off everything in their store when you
go to davidpakman.com
watch if you're looking for an awesome
way to
update your look the perfect way to do
it is with an elegant
high quality wrist watch when there's a
company like vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch vincero
is an american company
that's made it possible to own an
excellent watch
without breaking the bank all of their
watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 off everything in
their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video